that poor bastard I just keep thinking
about him he was fun to party with cops
ever cave just like roll me down a hill
cuz he can't run oh is he in a
wheelchair he is now yeah by the time
but back then he meant like literally
roll him down the hill yeah roll down we
had to do that a couple
times to get him out of there yeah
nah oh yeah how listen that's how you
had to help your friend with muscular
disty get away from the cops he
literally him down a
hill all the trees and too
yeah oh he he's a good sport about
it we used to vote him he couldn't smile
all his muscles right so we used to vote
him best smile in high
school the Honeydew with y'all subscribe
[Music]
today